[Music]
we're going to deploy a virtual machine
using cloud deployment manager using
cloud shell click the pencil at the top
to open the text editor in the file menu
choose new file and name it VM llamo
paste the config file from the
QuickStart into this file first to find
the virtual machine instance using this
config file this establishes the machine
Type image family zone disk and IP
replace the placeholder variables in the
new llamo file with your preferred
project and VM image family there are
two instances of my project and one
instance of family name deploy these
resources using G cloud referencing the
yamo file just created your deployment
has succeeded we now have a new instance
deployed it's quick to check on your
deployment with the described command in
G cloud which shows us the information
about a deployment plus any warnings or
errors moving to the cloud console web
UI we can see that our deployment is
shown in the deployment manager section
clicking in gives us more information
about the resources included and we can
get details on the VM from here as well
you've now completed your first
deployment congratulations
[Music]